في اخبارنا الاخرى قالت شرطه الفرنسيه ان
ثلاثه اشخاص جرحوا في عمليه طعن بالعاصمه
باريس اصابه احدهم وصفت بالخطر وفق
التقارير الاوليه واضافت الشرطه انها القت
القبض على منفذ العمليه التي لم تتضح
ملابساتها
بعد من باريس ينضم الينا مراسل جزيره لطفي
المسعودي لطفي ما هو مصير المعتقل متهم في
هذه العمليه وهل علمت
[موسيقى]
دوافعه فدا الى حدود اللحظه تقول الشرطه
الفرنسيه انه لا وجود لقرائنا على ان
حادثه الطعن ذات طبيعه ارهابيه وتقول ان
التحقيق مستمر لتحديد الدوافع الحقيقيه
وراء هذا الهجوم الذي ارتكبه شاب تقول انه
يبلغ من العمر 32 عاما وانها وجدت معه
رخصه سياقه ايطاليه ولكن هذا في نظرها لا
يحدد حتى هويته ان كان ايطاليا او يعني لم
تقل ان كان ايطاليا او مجنس ايطالي او
يحمل فقط رخصه سياقه ايطاليه هي قالت فقط
انها وجدت لديه رخصه سياقه ايطاليه وانه
يبلغ من العمر 32 عاما
واستنطاقه
في المرحله الاوليه تقول انه يبدو عليه
علامات اضطرابات النفسي لذلك فهي الى حدود
اللحظه تقول انه لا وجود لقرائنا قويه تدل
على ان هذه الحادثه هي ذات الطبيعه
ارهابيه فدا فدا الحادثه حدثت في حدود
الساعه الثامنه بتوقيت باريس اي العاشره
بتوقيت الدوحه والثلاثه الذين اصيبوا بج
روح لا احد منهم تقول الشرطه ان ان حياته
مهدده مع ان اثنين من المصابين حالتهما
يعني جروحه ما طفيفه والاخر وضعه حرج الى
حد ما ولكن الشرطه تقول ان حياته غير
مهدده بسبب هذه الاصابه فيدا شكرا لك لطفي
المسعودي مراسل الجزيره من باريس